.
Eine 75-jährige Frau
macht sich in Basel auf den Weg,
um einen siebenjährigen Buben
zu erstechen.
Alice F. begeht die Tat
laut Psychiater im "Querulantenwahn".
Erklären Sie einmal einer Opfer-
familie, was schuldunfähig bedeutet.
Er hatte so viele Träume.
Und dann
kommt so eine Psychopathin ...
... und nimmt ihm einfach das Leben.
An der Zürcher Goldküste
nimmt Bennet S. so viele Drogen,
dass er seinen Kollegen Alex tötet -
angeblich im Wahn.
Er wurde totgeschlagen, erwürgt,
erstickt -
mit einer Kerze im Rachen,
ganz übel zugerichtet.
Der Schmerz ist ...
... unbeschreiblich.
Die Gerichte
tun sich schwer mit der Frage,
ob und wie Verbrechen im Wahn
zu bestrafen sind.
Klar ist:
Wahn kann tödliche Folgen haben.
Z.B. 2001 in Zug:
Dort tötet der schon lange auffällige
Friedrich Leibacher 14 Menschen.
Die meisten Drohungen,
die meisten querulatorischen
Menschen sind harmlos.
Die Polizei
versucht frühzeitig festzustellen,
wo sich ein gefährlicher Wahn
abzeichnet.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Unheimliche Klänge *
Das Gotthelf-Schulhaus in Basel.
Hier ging der siebenjährige Ilias
in die erste Klasse.
Seine Eltern stammen aus dem Kosovo.
Der Junge war aufgeweckt, fröhlich -
ein Sonnenschein für die Eltern.
* Unheimliche Klänge *
Dann passierte etwas,
was keiner je vergessen wird.
Ich nahm
ein Telefongespräch entgegen,
bei dem mir
eine Lehrerin sagte:
"Es ist
etwas Schreckliches passiert."
"Ein Kind unserer Klasse
blutet aus dem Hals."
"Die Ambulanz ist avisiert."
"Aber ich weiss nicht,
was mit diesem Kind los ist."
Ein Bub
wird auf dem Schulweg angegriffen
und durch einen Messerstich
schwer verletzt.
Eine ältere Frau
tötete gestern in Basel ein Kind.
Eine 75-jährige Schweizerin
erstach gestern in Basel
aus heiterem Himmel einen sieben-
jährigen Buben auf der Strasse.
* Schwermütige Klänge *
Die Mutter des toten Jungen
auf dem Weg zu seinem Grab.
Ilias ist im Kosovo begraben.
Sie sei viel zu selten hier.
Ilias liegt
auf dem Friedhof von Gjilan.
Das Ehepaar Mahmuti besucht ihn,
zusammen mit seinen zwei Kindern.
Ilias war ihr Erstgeborener.
Dass eine fremde Frau
ihn im Wahn erstochen hat,
wissen seine Geschwister nicht.
Hier schläft dein Bruder.
Ilias hört dich immer.
- Wo?- Egal, wo du bist.
Knapp vier Jahre ist es her,
seit der Bub ermordet wurde.
Seine Eltern
gingen seither durch die Hölle.
Die Zeit heilt alle Wunden -
das stimmt vielleicht für viele,
für uns eben nicht.
Jeden Tag wird es noch schlimmer,
es wird nicht besser.
Und nur ich und er wissen,
was wir alles durchmachen müssen.
Immer, wenn wir traurig sind,
müssen wir lachen,
damit die Kinder nichts merken.
Und das ist auch sehr schwer,
v.a. für mich als Mutter.
Bereits zwei Tage nach seinem Tod
wurde Ilias
in seiner Heimat zu Grabe getragen.
Es sollte zügig gehen.
Sein Vater sagt,
je schneller Moslems beerdigt würden,
desto einfacher
kämen sie in den Himmel.
* Islamischer Klagegesang *
Hier
im Untersuchungsgefängnis in Basel
sitzt die Täterin
seit dreieinhalb Jahren.
Ihr Fall
ist noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Doch egal,
wie das endgültige Urteil aussieht:
Alice F. fühlt sich befreit, seit sie
den Schuljungen umgebracht hat -
von Reue keine Spur.
In den Gerichtsakten steht:
"Sie fühlt sich erleichtert und fit."
"Ihre Schlafprobleme
seien verschwunden."
Psychiater Steffen Lau
hat eine Erklärung dafür.
Man muss sich vorstellen,
dass sie ein Fanal gesetzt hat,
ein letztes Zeichen.
Und offenbar hat sie
vielleicht in ihrem Erleben
jetzt
eine Reaktion des Systems erlebt,
die sie insofern befriedigt,
als dass sie ...
... weiterhin
ihren Kampf führen kann
Da kriegt sie
möglicherweise die Aufmerksamkeit,
von der sie denkt,
dass sie notwendig ist,
um das vor 20-30 Jahren
entstandene Problem zu lösen.
Vor 30 Jahren flogen Alice F. und ihr
damaliger Freund aus ihrer Wohnung.
Es gab eine Zwangsräumung.
Später lebte Alice F.
in diesem Hotel in Basel.
Ihre grösste Angst war,
obdachlos zu werden.
Getrieben von ihrem Wahn
verfasst sie in ihrem Zimmer
kryptische Briefe an die Behörden.
Ans Bundesgericht schreibt sie etwa,
dass sie die abverlangte Gewalttat
jederzeit
einhalten und beweisen werde
und entsprechende Notwehrmassnahmen
einleite.
Heute ist klar: Damit
kündigte die Rentnerin ihren Mord an.
Alice F. hat die Behörden
jahrzehntelang angegriffen.
Bei der Zwangsräumung vor 30 Jahren
sei ihr Eigentum liquidiert worden.
Sie witterte
eine Justizkorruptionsaffäre.
Ihr Ton wurde immer giftiger.
Die Behörden
gaben sich unbeeindruckt.
In den Akten steht,
es habe sich eine Korrespondenz
von über zehn
gefüllten Bananenkisten angehäuft.
Seit 1983 seien die Briefe
grossmehrheitlich
nicht mehr beantwortet worden.
Die Basler Behörden wollen sich
nicht zum Fall Alice F. äussern,
weil es ein laufendes Verfahren sei.
Irgendwann muss eine Behörde
so jemanden ignorieren,
weil sie sonst ihrer Arbeit
nicht mehr nachgehen kann.
Das nimmt ja
immer grössere Formen an.
Und irgendwann
muss man einen Riegel schieben.
Die Betroffenen
verharren in einer Haltung,
dass das System gegen sie ist.
Und jede Aktion, die nicht zu 100 %
ihren Vorstellungen entspricht,
wird als Beweis,
als Bestätigung dafür genommen,
dass das System
unvollkommen und fehlerhaft ist.
Das irre Motiv von Alice F.:
Sie tötete ein Kind,
damit sich die Behörden endlich
mit ihrer angeblich
skandalösen Zwangsräumung
von vor 30 Jahren befassen mussten.
Südspanien.
Hier besitzt Katja Faber neben ihrem
Wohnsitz in der Schweiz eine Finca.
Im Moment
ist Erntezeit für Pekannüsse.
Draussen zu sein,
hat mir unglaublich geholfen.
Aber am wichtigsten ist,
sich zu bewegen
und in der Natur zu arbeiten.
Katja Fabers Sohn wurde 2014 getötet.
Die Gesellschaft
versteht Trauer nicht.
Und sie versteht
sicher auch Trauma nicht.
Ich bedaure die Art und Weise,
wie die Gesellschaft
Trauer betrachtet.
Viele Psychologen und Psychiater
scheinen zu denken,
dass es sich
um eine Krankheit handelt.
Darum werden vielen Menschen
Medikamente verschrieben.
Alex wurde 23 Jahre alt.
Er hatte gerade seinen Bachelor
in BWL und Spanisch gemacht
und einen Job gefunden in London,
in der Heimat seines Vaters.
Seine Mutter ist Schweizerin,
verbrachte aber einen grossen Teil
ihres Lebens in England
und spricht inzwischen
besser Englisch als Deutsch.
Ein sportlicher und
lebenslustiger junger Mann war er.
Das älteste von drei Kindern.
In gewisser Weise
war er recht schüchtern.
Er war immer in meiner Nähe.
Wenn ich bei ihm war,
ging er nicht zu weit weg.
Aber sobald er sich sicher fühlte,
war er das Zentrum der Party.
Die Leute
fühlten sich zu ihm hingezogen.
Er war sehr charismatisch.
Wenn er seinen Geburtstag feierte,
kamen alle Kinder.
Er war kontaktfreudig.
In diesem Sinne
war er ein einfaches Kind.
Ich machte mir keine Sorgen um ihn.
Wenn sie älter werden,
wird dir klar,
dass sie ins Auto steigen,
sie lernen zu fahren,
sie gehen auf Reisen.
Du kannst nicht kontrollieren,
wo sie sind.
Es können Unfälle passieren,
Dinge können schiefgehen -
so ist das Leben.
Du musst loslassen
und darauf vertrauen,
dass es gut kommt,
dass du sie so erzogen hast,
dass sie
vernünftige Entscheidungen treffen
und Situationen richtig einschätzen.
In den frühen Morgenstunden
des 30. Dezember 2014
macht sich Alex
zusammen mit einem Kollegen
auf den Heimweg von einer Party.
Etwa 2 Std. später wird er getötet.
Seine Mutter spürt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Ich wachte mit dem
allerschrecklichsten Albtraum auf.
Ich hatte die entsetzlichsten,
entsetzlichsten Dinge gesehen.
Ich sah etwas, das mir
wie das Gesicht von Alex vorkam
direkt neben mir.
Was ich gesehen hatte,
war so abscheulich,
dass mir schlecht wurde.
Am Zürcher Bellevue steigen Alex
und sein 29-jähriger Kollege
gegen 4 Uhr morgens in ein Taxi.
Sie fahren Richtung Küsnacht,
dort soll die Party weitergehen.
Christine Brand hat den Fall
als Gerichtsreporterin eng begleitet.
Klar sei: Die beiden Männer
hätten die elterliche Villa
von Bennet S. betreten,
dessen Familie im Skiurlaub war.
Dort muss etwas passiert sein.
Beide konsumierten nochmals Drogen.
Was genau passierte,
wissen wir nicht,
weil die einzige Person,
die darüber berichten könnte,
unterschiedliche
Tatvarianten erzählte
und am Schluss
gar nichts mehr sagte.
Aber das Resultat
dieser Nacht dort oben war,
dass Alex von seinem damaligen
Kollegen umgebracht wurde -
und zwar
auf äusserst brutale Art und Weise.
Er wurde totgeschlagen, erwürgt,
erstickt -
mit einer Kerze im Rachen,
ganz übel zugerichtet.
Nachdem der Täter
die Tat begangen hatte,
nahm er eine Dusche.
Danach rief er seinen Vater an,
der nicht ans Telefon ging.
Dann rief er die Polizei an
und sagte als erstes:
"Mein Kollege ging auf mich los,
er wollte mich umbringen."
"Ich bin verletzt."
Und dann: "Mein Kollege ist tot."
Als Alex in Küsnacht getötet wird,
ist seine Mutter
mit seinen beiden Geschwistern
auf ihrer Finca in Spanien.
Es gehe um ihren Sohn,
sagt ihr die Kantonspolizei Zürich
lediglich am Telefon.
Was mit Alex sei, würden ihr
spanische Beamte mitteilen.
Ich ging nach draussen.
Und es war so kalt.
Ich sah einen jungen Polizisten
und eine junge Polizistin.
Und ich dachte: "Sie schicken
eine Frau, weil es so schlimm ist."
Ich sagte, ich muss mich hinsetzen.
Ich setzte mich hin, und der
Polizist schaute mich an und sagte:
"Su hijo ha fallecido."
D.h.: "Ihr Sohn ist tot."
Das ist, als ob dich
jemand so hart schlagen würde,
dass du nicht mehr atmen kannst.
Ich musste
aus dem Zimmer rausrennen.
Ich schrie und schrie und schrie.
Dieser Schmerz ist unbeschreiblich,
absolut unbeschreiblich.
Wenn du selbst
kein Kind verloren hast,
kannst du dir nicht vorstellen,
wie das ist.
Katja Faber und ihre beiden Kinder
fliegen am nächsten Tag
in die Schweiz - zu Alex.
Ich erinnere mich, wie ich dachte:
Ich will ihn halten, ihm mit meinen
Händen durch die Haare fahren,
seinen Duft einatmen.
Ich will mich
von ihm verabschieden.
Aber mir wurde gesagt:
"Schau ihn dir nicht an,
denn dieses Bild wird dir bleiben."
Alex war seine Privatsphäre
sehr wichtig.
Ich dachte, er würde nicht wollen,
dass ich ihn so sehe.
Bevor ich zu ihm ging,
verschlossen sie den Sarg.
Ich ging dorthin
und sass in diesem Raum.
Ich berührte das kalte Holz
und versuchte, ihn mir vorzustellen,
seinen perfekten Körper, den jemand
unvollkommen gemacht hatte.
Ich sass dort für Stunden.
Rund zweieinhalb Jahre nach der Tat
kommt es zum Prozess
vor dem Bezirksgericht Meilen.
Bennet S., inzwischen 32,
deutscher Staatsbürger, Student,
muss sich für den Tod
von Alex Faber verantworten.
Der Täter machte von Anfang an
immer wieder andere Aussagen.
Grundsätzlich gilt bei der Polizei,
dass die erste Aussage
die glaubwürdigste ist,
weil es frisch ist,
und er noch keine Zeit hatte,
ein Lügengebilde zu erstellen.
Bei der ersten Aussage
stellte er sich besser dar,
sagte damals schon,
er sei angegriffen worden.
Das zieht sich eigentlich
durch alle Aussagen durch.
Er stellte sich als anständigen,
netten, friedliebenden Menschen dar
und versuchte,
das Opfer schlechtzumachen.
Gleichzeitig merkte man
von Anfang an, dass seine Aussagen
nicht mit dem Verletzungsbild
des Opfers übereinstimmen.
Fast alle seine Aussagen
konnten widerlegt werden.
Es ist ganz klar: Von Anfang an
gab er Schutzbehauptungen von sich.
Er wies die Schuld dem anderen zu -
und er war dabei
v.a. nicht konstant.
Erst sagte er,
es sei Notwehr gewesen.
Dann sagte er,
beim Versuch sich zu wehren
sei ihm der Kerzenständer
aus der Hand geglitten,
später, er habe
überhaupt nicht mehr zugeschlagen,
obwohl alles
seinen Behauptungen widersprach.
Dann sagte er: "Ich kann mich
nicht mehr an diese Tat erinnern."
Dem Gutachter sagte er, das Opfer
sei ihm als Alien erschienen.
Seine Argumentation war sprunghaft.
Er versuchte von Anfang an,
sich zu schützen,
die Tat herunterzuspielen -
es sei ihm einfach so passiert.
Und je länger er
verschiedene Varianten auftischte -
er wollte einfach
seinen Kopf retten.
Er versuchte, seinen Kopf
aus der Schlinge zu ziehen.
Er hoffte, eine möglichst
kleine Strafe zu kassieren.
Wieso tötete Bennet S.
seinen Kollegen?
Diese Frage muss das
Bezirksgericht Meilen 2017 klären.
Hat er im Drogenwahn gehandelt?
Ist er schuldfähig?
Und wie ist er zu bestrafen?
* Schwebende Klänge *
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Es ist der 21. März 2019,
Frühlingsanfang.
Alice F. geht unruhig
durch den Schützenmattpark in Basel.
Die Wahnvorstellung, töten zu müssen,
um endlich zu ihrem Recht zu kommen,
wird immer drängender.
Den Passanten
fällt die 75-Jährige nicht auf.
Sie ist immer gut gekleidet,
wirkt gepflegt.
Dieses Foto
zeigt sie am Gerichtsprozess.
Artan Sadiku, der Anwalt der
Opferfamilie, ist ihr dort begegnet.
Sie war sehr anständig,
sehr freundlich, sehr eloquent.
Man würde nicht glauben ...
Man könnte ihr
im Zug gegenübersitzen ...
... und könnte wahrscheinlich
das freundlichste,
oberflächlichste Gespräch führen,
wie man es in einem Zug führen kann.
Und man würde nie daran denken -
so ist es mir ergangen -,
dass so eine freundliche,
ältere Dame ...
... eine so schlimme Tat
begehen kann.
Dass die Frau psychisch krank ist,
wissen die Behörden
allerdings seit vielen Jahren.
Zweimal ist Alice F. bereits
in die geschlossene Psychiatrie
eingeliefert worden.
Erst jetzt ist klar,
wie schlimm ihre Krankheit ist.
Die Gutachter
attestieren ihr einen Querulantenwahn
und schätzen das Rückfallrisiko
als hoch ein.
Die Täterin
hält sich in der Mittagszeit
in der Nähe
des Gotthelf-Schulhauses auf,
wo um 12.15 Uhr
die Pausenglocke läutet.
* Glocke *
Sie weiss, dass um diese Uhrzeit
viele Kinder unterwegs sind.
Das spätere Opfer Ilias Mahmuti
verlässt das Schulhaus als Letzter
um 12.30 Uhr - er ist allein.
7 Min. später holt Alice F.
das Messer aus ihrer Handtasche
und sticht zu.
Die Täterin lief hinter ihm her,
zückte das Messer
und stach rechts auf ihn ein.
Sie konnte das Messer herausziehen,
er drehte sich um,
und dann stach sie links zu.
Dann sackte er zusammen
und verstarb später im Spital.
Wenn man sich vorstellt,
zwei Stiche in den Hals -
dazu musste sich der Bub umdrehen
und musste ihr
noch in die Augen schauen.
Aus seiner Sicht ...
Dass das die letzten Bilder
eines Buben sein müssen:
eine ältere Dame zu sehen,
die er zuvor noch nie
in seinem Leben gesehen hat,
wie Blut herausspritzt,
und er nochmals sieht,
wie auf ihn eingestochen wird.
Das stelle ich mir
sehr, sehr schlimm vor.
Alice F. hat kein Mitleid
mit dem Kind, nur mit sich selbst.
In der Vernehmung sagt sie später:
Noch während sie das Messer in der
Hand gehalten habe, habe sie gedacht:
"Warum muss ich so leiden?"
Sie lief ganz normal,
sie rannte nicht.
Sie war voller Blut, das Messer
hielt sie noch in der Hand.
Sie war ganz ruhig.
Ja, ganz normal,
als ob nichts passiert wäre.
Sie lieg weg.
- Als wäre ein Tier gestorben.
Sie blickte zurück, wartete.
Bis heute liegen am Tatort
Blumen und Spielzeug.
Die Eltern
erinnern sich an jede Einzelheit,
als die Nachricht kam,
dem Buben sei etwas zugestossen.
Ich bin dann heulend ...
... bis zur Busstation gelaufen.
Ich weiss nicht einmal mehr, ob ich
die Haustüre abgeschlossen habe.
Keine Ahnung,
ich war einfach voller Tränen.
Alle Buspassagiere sahen es,
dass ...
Weisst du, alle wussten,
was passiert war, ausser uns,
alle wussten es.
In den Nachrichtenportalen
kam bereits die Eilmeldung,
dass ein Schulbub auf dem Heimweg
schwer verletzt worden sei.
Später, als alles vorbei war,
übergab die Polizei den Eltern
die Habseligkeiten ihres Sohnes.
Das sind seine Finken.
- Die er in der Schule trug.
Und das ist sein Trinkbecher.
Das ist sein Tagesbuch.
Ich rieche ...
... wie soll ich sagen ...
... seinen Körperduft.
Das sind unsere Andenken.
Seine Kleider werde ich nie waschen.
Die ganze Stadt ist erschüttert.
Die Schule
organisiert einen Kondolenztermin.
Wildfremde Leute kommen vorbei,
um Familie Mahmuti
ihr Beileid auszusprechen.
Die Kinder, die mit Ilias zur Schule
gingen, haben kaum verstanden,
was vorgefallen ist.
Es waren Erstklässler,
denen man einfach sagen muss:
"Es ist etwas Schlimmes passiert
und Ilias ist leider gestorben."
Es war natürlich bekannt,
dass es eine ältere Frau ist.
Und das löste bei Eltern
und auch bei den Kindern ...
Normalerweise
geben ältere Personen Sicherheit:
"Wenn du Angst hast, dann frage
doch vielleicht eine ältere Frau."
Das kam plötzlich ins Wanken.
Alice F. sitzt seit fast vier Jahren
in Untersuchungshaft.
Sie soll verwahrt werden -
dagegen kämpft sie vehement.
Sie sei weder gefährlich noch
wahnsinnig, sondern geistig normal.
Ihre Gutachter sehen es anders.
Alice F.
sei nicht krankheitseinsichtig.
Die Erfolgsaussichten
einer Behandlung
lägen darum unter einem Drittel
Alice F. will nicht behandelt werden,
schon gar nicht mit Medikamenten.
Sie bleibt gefangen in ihrem Wahn
und sieht sich weiter
als Opfer einer korrupten Justiz.
* Schwebende Klänge *
Katja Fabers Sohn Alex ist auf
dem Friedhof in Zollikon begraben.
Hier besucht sie ihn regelmässig.
Dass er tot ist, bedeutet nicht,
dass ich ihn nicht mehr liebe.
Ich denke nicht, dass er hier ist.
Aber vielleicht ist er es -
ich weiss es nicht.
Vielleicht ist er irgendwo,
oder nirgendwo.
Aber hier habe ich einen Ort,
wo ich hingehen
und weiter eine Mutter sein kann.
Die Frage, wieso Katja Fabers Sohn
im Alter von 23 Jahren getötet wurde,
ist bis heute ungeklärt.
* Schwebende Klänge *
Als der Fall 2017 am Bezirksgericht
Meilen verhandelt wird,
ist lediglich klar: Täter und Opfer
hatten Drogen konsumiert.
Ketamin, ein Narkosemittel,
das Halluzinationen hervorrufen kann,
und Kokain.
Der Täter macht von seinem
Recht zu Schweigen Gebrauch.
Zu sehen, dass er nicht antwortete,
machte mich unglaublich traurig,
dass wir nie herausfinden werden,
was in jener Nacht
wirklich passiert ist.
So schwer es auch gewesen wäre,
das zu hören -
es wäre das Mindeste gewesen,
zu erklären, was passiert ist.
Bis heute hat er nichts erklärt.
Wissen Sie, das ist unverzeihlich,
das ist wirklich unverzeihlich.
Im Prozess gegen Bennet S.
spielt dessen Vorleben
eine entscheidende Rolle,
insbesondere sein Drogenkonsum
und sein Verhalten, wenn er high war.
Der Täter, der Galeristensohn,
hatte schon lange ein Drogenproblem.
Das hat eigentlich schon
während seiner Schulzeit begonnen
und steigerte sich.
Er bekam von seiner Familie
viel Geld zur Verfügung gestellt,
wohnte in einer 4'000-Fr.-Wohnung,
die der Vater zahlte
und erhielt monatlich
5'000 Fr. Taschengeld,
das er v.a. ins Partyleben
und in Drogen investierte.
Und diese Drogen-
und Medikamentenabhängigkeit
hatte Auswirkungen
auf sein Verhalten.
Er wurde mehrfach
ausfällig und auffällig.
Seine Freundin erzählte vor Gericht,
dass er in Klubs
manchmal ausgetickt war,
sodass sie ihn beruhigen
und nach Hause bringen musste.
Es kam auch zu Übergriffen
auf seine Freundin selber.
Er vergewaltigte sie brutal -
auch unter Einfluss von Ketamin.
Er wollte sie angeblich
aus dem Auto stossen,
aber dafür
wurde er nicht verurteilt,
weil Aussage gegen Aussage stand.
Und er hat auch schon
unter Einfluss von Ketamin
den eigenen Vater angegriffen,
der zum Nachbar flüchten musste.
Schon damals sagte er, er denke,
eine Verschwörung laufe gegen ihn,
und sein Vater
sei ihm als Zauberer erschienen.
Er wusste,
dass er nach Einnahme dieser Drogen
austickte und gewalttätig wurde.
Deswegen landete er auch schon
in der psychiatrischen Klinik.
Es war keine Überraschung,
wenn man seinen Lebenslauf
betrachtet,
dass er unter Drogeneinfluss
gewalttätig wurde.
Das Bezirksgericht Meilen
verurteilt ihn
wegen der Vergewaltigung
seiner Ex-Freundin
und wegen der vorsätzlichen Tötung
von Alex Faber zu 12 1/2 Jahren.
Dass ihm sein Kollege im Drogenwahn
als Alien erschienen sei,
glaubt ihm das Gericht nicht.
Bennet S. zieht das Urteil weiter
ans Obergericht.
2019 kommt es
zur Berufungsverhandlung.
Die Angehörigen des Opfers
sind nicht mehr im Gerichtssaal.
Um dem Täter
nicht begegnen zu müssen,
haben sie um eine Video-Übertragung
in einen anderen Raum gebeten.
Ich musste mir anhören,
wie die Richter den Täter fragten:
"Wie schlafen Sie?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?"
"Wie ist es für Sie?"
Ich weiss noch, wie ich dachte:
"Worüber reden die?"
"Wieso kümmert es sie,
wie er schläft?"
"Wen interessiert es,
"Er hat jemanden getötet.
Er hat jemanden vergewaltigt."
"Fragt mich, wie ich schlafe!"
"Habe ich geschlafen,
seit mein Sohn getötet wurde?"
Was um alles in der Welt
sollte das?
"Wie schlafen Sie?
Es muss schwer sein für Sie."
Als sie diese Dinge fragten,
erstarrte ich.
Und ich dachte:
"Das ist nicht gut."
Das Obergericht spricht Bennet S.
vom Vorwurf der Vergewaltigung frei.
Und es glaubt ihm,
dass ihm sein Kollege im Drogenwahn
als Alien erschienen sei.
Es wendet Artikel 263
des Strafgesetzbuches an.
Dieser besagt: "Wer infolge
selbstverschuldeter Trunkenheit
oder Betäubung
unzurechnungsfähig ist
und in diesem Zustand
ein Verbrechen begeht,
kann mit höchstens
drei Jahren bestraft werden."
Ich war sehr überrascht vom Urteil.
Es ist wirklich selten,
dass ein Urteil so stark kippt.
Wenn man dieses Delikt betrachtet
mit dieser
massiven Gewalteinwirkung,
will es einem
fast nicht in den Kopf gehen,
dass der Täter
nachher nur drei Jahre bekommt.
Wenn man bedenkt,
dass sich jemand durch Drogenkonsum
in einen Zustand versetzt,
in dem er gewalttätig wird ...
Würde das beim ersten Mal passieren,
und der Täter wüsste nicht,
dass er gewalttätig wird
von den Drogen,
dann wäre es noch ein anderes Thema.
Aber dieser Täter wusste,
dass er unter Drogeneinfluss
gewalttätig werden konnte.
Eigentlich hätte er ...
Bevor er die Drogen nahm,
war er bei klarem Verstand.
Dann hätte er abschätzen können,
dass er dadurch
gefährlich werden könnte.
So gesehen
war es für mich schwierig,
eine selbstverschuldete Unzu-
rechnungsfähigkeit nachzuvollziehen.
Aber
dieser Gesetzesartikel existiert,
die Maximalstrafe
beträgt nun einmal drei Jahre.
Und so, wie das Gericht
argumentierte, dachte ich:
"Gut, wenn es ihm glaubt,
muss es diesen Artikel anwenden."
An der juristischen Fakultät
der Universität Zürich
wurde dieses Urteil
kontrovers diskutiert.
Marc Thommen machte es zum Thema
in einer seiner Vorlesungen -
insbesondere die Frage,
wieso das Obergericht
keinen Vorsatz erkennen konnte.
Für eine Vorsatzverurteilung
braucht es zwei Bedingungen:
Entweder muss er
von Anfang an geplant haben,
seinen Jugendfreund umzubringen,
aber das steht
überhaupt nicht zur Diskussion.
Das wurde ihm nie vorgeworfen und
wäre an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Die zweite Möglichkeit
wäre ein sog. Eventualvorsatz.
Man hätte vorhersehen können,
dass das passieren würde
und man das in Kauf genommen hat -
salopp gesagt, dass es ihm egal war,
dass es passiert.
Und das ist
eine relativ hohe Schranke,
ihm diese Inkaufnahme
nachweisen zu können.
Das könnte man dann machen,
wenn man sagt:
Aus einer progredienten Geschichte
von vergangenem Drogenkonsum,
bei denen es zu Übergriffen kam,
hatte man
mehr oder weniger sicher vor Augen,
dass es wieder
zu solchen Übergriffen kommt.
Dabei hat man in Kauf genommen ...
Man hat also
seine eigene Drogensucht
oder seinen eigenen Willen,
Drogen zu konsumieren,
über die mögliche Folge gestellt.
Das Vorleben des Täters
ist also zentral.
Konkret:
Hat er z.B. in London
seine damalige Freundin vergewaltigt
unter Drogeneinfluss?
Und hat er high versucht,
sie aus einem fahrenden Taxi
zu stossen und damit zu töten?
Für das Obergericht sind
diese Sachverhalte nicht erstellt.
Darum musste Bennet S.
auch nicht wissen,
wozu er im Drogenwahn fähig ist.
Wenn man einen Tötungsversuch
nicht erstellen kann,
nicht erstellen kann, dass es schon
vorher eine Vergewaltigung gab,
dann kann man es ihm
auch nicht vorhalten.
Vor diesem Hintergrund
sind die unterschiedlichen Urteile
am besten verständlich,
weil sie von unterschiedlich
erstellten Sachverhalten ausgehen.
Darum sagte ich:
Wenn man das unterstellt,
kann man die Vorhersehbarkeit
gut begründen.
Aber wenn man sagt:
Weder die Vergewaltigung
noch die versuchte Tötung
waren erstellt,
dann wird es schwierig,
jemandem zu sagen:
"Du hättest in einer
solchen Situation wissen müssen,
dass du
einen Jugendfreund umbringst."
Die Staatsanwaltschaft zieht
das Urteil weiter ans Bundesgericht.
Dieses schickt den Fall
sozusagen zurück an den Absender.
Es liess kein gutes Haar
am Urteil des Obergerichts,
am ersten Urteil des Obergerichts.
Es sprach von Willkür,
von Fehlern, die begangen wurden.
Es war eigentlich wirklich ...
... eines der
schlechtesten Zeugnisse,
die das Bundesgericht je
einem Obergericht ausgestellt hatte.
Das Bundesgericht
kritisiert den Freispruch
vom Vorwurf der Vergewaltigung,
aber auch, dass das Obergericht
dem Täter glaubte,
er habe seinen Kollegen im Drogenwahn
als bedrohliches Alien gesehen.
Im ersten Urteil des Obergerichts
stützten sich die Richter
v.a. auf die Aussagen
des psychiatrischen Gutachters.
Dieser
psychiatrische Gutachter sagte:
"Der Täter erzählte mir, er habe
das Opfer als Alien gesehen."
Das Bundesgericht sagte,
das sei ein Fehler.
Das Obergericht hätte
nicht auf eine Aussage bauen dürfen,
die gegenüber
einem forensischen Psychiater
zum Tatgeschehen gemacht wurde,
weil man nicht weiss, wie diese
Aussage zustande gekommen war,
vielleicht gab es
auch Suggestivfragen.
Das ist nicht vergleichbar
mit einer Aussage
bei einer polizeilichen Einvernahme.
Darum dürfe sich das Obergericht
nicht auf diese Aussage stützen.
Das Bundesgericht kritisiert
auch den forensischen Psychiater,
weil der Psychiater
eigentlich Fragen stellen müssten,
die sich
um die Psyche des Täters drehen -
und nicht um den Tatablauf.
Meines Erachtens beging
das Gericht den grossen Fehler,
als es diese Aussage verwertete.
Im Sommer 2022 berät das Zürcher
Obergericht erneut über den Fall.
Es befindet nun: Bennet S.
habe seine Ex-Freundin vergewaltigt
und Alex Faber vorsätzlich getötet.
Er bekommt zwölf Jahre
und muss eine Suchtbehandlung machen.
Inzwischen
ist dieses Urteil rechtskräftig.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Katja Faber hat angefangen,
Texte über Trauer und den Verlust
von Kindern zu publizieren.
Sie sei überrascht
von der grossen Resonanz.
Mit vielen Betroffenen entwickle sich
ein intensiver Austausch.
Ich tue, was ich kann,
um ihrer Trauer Raum zu geben
und sie spüren zu lassen,
dass es jemanden gibt,
der vielleicht verstehen kann,
was sie durchmachen.
Das hilft auch mir selbst.
Denn anderen zu helfen,
unterstützt
meine Reise des Weiterlebens.
Zu schreiben
war lebenswichtig für mich,
weil es mich
mir selbst näherbrachte.
Und in gewisser Weise
auch anderen Menschen,
die die gleiche Trauer
durchgemacht haben.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Die Eltern bleiben stundenlang
am Grab ihres ermordeten Buben.
Hier fühlen sie sich
ihrem verlorenen Sohn besonders nah.
Ich akzeptiere es einfach nicht.
Er hatte so viele Träume.
Weisst du, er träumte immer davon,
was er arbeiten würde,
wenn er gross sein würde,
was er alles unternehmen würde.
Und dann kommt ...
... so eine Psychopathin ...
... und nimmt ihm einfach das Leben.
In die Trauer mischt sich
die Wut über die Rentnerin,
die den Buben
im Wahn erstochen hat.
Der kleine Ilias
wurde keine acht Jahre alt.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich würde sie gerne fragen,
ob sie glücklich ist,
ob sie erreicht hat,
was sie wollte.
Denn für uns
hat sie nicht nur Ilias getötet,
sondern sie hat
uns alle als Familie getötet.
Alice F.
hat die Tat nie abgestritten.
Das Gericht befindet,
sie habe im Wahn gehandelt.
Das Urteil vom August 2020
ist paradox:
Die Angeklagte
habe zwar einen Mord begangen,
sei aber nicht schuldfähig,
und werde daher nicht bestraft.
Weil sie gefährlich sei, wird sie
verwahrt, also präventiv weggesperrt.
Es fällt nicht so leicht zu sagen,
dass es ein Unfall war,
denn es wirkte wie geplant.
Gab es etwas,
woran man das hätte erkennen können?
Und dann
sagen forensische Psychiater:
"Diese Frau ist nicht verantwortlich
zu machen für das Geschehene."
Das macht es für die Familie
umso schwieriger zu akzeptieren,
dass das passiert ist.
Nach der Tat
wollte Alice F. glaubhaft machen,
der Mord sei im Affekt geschehen.
Schnell fanden die Ermittler heraus,
dass dies nicht stimmen kann.
Am Abend vor der Tat
sass die mittellose Rentnerin
in ihrem Hotelzimmer und schrieb
eine SMS, die sie nicht abschickte,
sondern als Entwurf speicherte.
"Hallo ihr Lieben, habe getötet,
damit ich das entzogene Eigentum
zurückbekomme."
Warum so ein Entwurf?
Die wirre Erklärung von Alice F.:
"Ich hatte Panik,
was mit mir passiert,
wenn ich in diese Situation komme."
"Ich musste meine Leute
schnell informieren,
bevor sie mich gepackt hätten."
Drei Tage
nach dem Mord auf offener Strasse
bildet sich in Basel
ein Trauermarsch.
Es ist ein Samstag,
Tausende Menschen versammeln sich.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Die Stimmung war sehr ruhig.
Es war sehr still.
Es war keine Demonstration,
sondern wirklich ein Trauermarsch.
Doch nicht alle
verspüren stille Trauer.
Einige sind wütend,
halten Plakate hoch.
Psychisch labil = Recht auf Mord?
Man wolle keinen zweiten Fall Ilias
mehr erleben.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Dass Wahn tödliche Folgen haben kann,
wurde der Schweiz am 27. September
2001 schmerzhaft bewusst.
14 Politikerinnen und Politiker
wurden damals in Zug erschossen.
Der Täter: Friedrich Leibacher, 57,
IV-Rentner, Querulant.
Er hatte
ein ganzes Waffenarsenal dabei,
als er das Kantonsparlament betrat.
Gekleidet war er
in einer selbst gefertigten Uniform
mit der Aufschrift "Polizei".
Hätte das Gewaltpotenzial
erkannt werden können?
Diese Frage
stellte sich schon damals.
Frank Urbaniok
war Gutachter im Fall Leibacher.
Er beurteilt regelmässig Querulanten.
Die meisten Drohungen,
die meisten querulatorischen
Menschen sind harmlos,
die überwiegende Anzahl
ist harmlos.
Es sei denn, es ist das,
was ich einen Q+ nenne.
Q+ heisst, dass zum Querulatorischen
eine weitere Problematik dazukommt.
Das können
ganz verschiedene Sachen sein.
Das kann
z.B. ein Verfolgungswahn sein.
z.B. eine Affinität zu Waffen sein.
Das kann z.B. eine
generelle Gewaltbereitschaft sein.
Das kann z.B. eine personen-
spezifische Feindseligkeit sein,
dass sich eine Person
total eingeschossen hat
auf eine Personengruppe
oder eine bestimmte Person,
eine tunnelartige Einengung erlebt
und sich
auf diese Person einschiesst.
Friedrich Leibacher
hatte eine Wut auf den Staat,
von dem er sich verraten fühlte.
Er wollte
für Recht und Ordnung sorgen.
Innert 2 Min. und 34 Sek.
erschoss er 14 Menschen.
Insgesamt 91 Schüsse feuerte er ab.
Danach richtete er sich selbst.
Leibacher kam immer wieder
mit dem Gesetz in Konflikt -
den Behörden war er bestens bekannt.
Leibacher ist der typische Fall
von keinem einfachen Querulanten.
Er ist ein typischer, extremer Q+,
weil das querulatorische Verhalten
nur eine Facette
des ganzen Risikoprofils war.
Er war ein gewaltbereiter Mensch,
der von Kindheit an
zu Gewalt gegriffen hat,
der hochmanipulativ war,
der in multiplen Situationen
mit der Justiz zu tun hatte,
der ein Spektrum
von Sexual- zu Gewaltdelikten hatte.
Er war immer sehr gut darin,
das zu verstecken, das zu verbergen,
die Schuld umzukehren: Er ist
das Opfer, die andern sind schuld.
Ich würde sagen, er war ein Q++++.
Die Tat schockierte die Schweiz
und warf grundsätzliche Fragen auf.
Wie erkennt man Menschen,
deren Wahn gefährlich wird?
Und welche Mittel hat der Staat,
um sie frühzeitig zu stoppen?
Es gibt
ein ganzes Spektrum von Massnahmen.
Und es hängt von der
konkreten Situation, dem Fall ab,
welche Massnahmen
richtig und anwendbar sind.
Ich gebe ein paar Beispiel dazu.
Es kann in einem Fall wichtig sein,
dass eine Waffe eingezogen wird.
Es kann sein,
dass man Drogenkonsum kontrolliert,
eine Drogenabstinenz verordnet,
dass man ein Rayonverbot ausspricht:
"Diese Person darf
nicht mehr da und dort hingehen."
Manchmal ist es wichtig,
die Dynamik rauszunehmen,
z.B. indem es bei einer konkreten
Drohung zu einer Inhaftierung kommt.
Bei einer psychiatrischen
Symptomatik könnte es sein,
dass die KESB einen
fürsorgerischen Freiheitsentzug
sowie
Therapie und Medikamente verordnet.
Es kann sein, dass die Polizei
eine Gefährderansprache macht
und damit die Luft rausnimmt.
Also es gibt wirklich
ein Bündel von Massnahmen.
Man kann nicht alles verhindern,
aber kann man viel tun,
wenn man das Instrumentarium kennt
und die Problematik erfasst hat.
Jeden Tag bekommt die Polizei
Anrufe von Leuten,
die auf Politiker und Verwaltung
schimpfen.
Wie umgehen mit
den immer zahlreicheren Wutbürgern?
Im Kanton Basel-Landschaft
gibt es Team von Experten,
das rechtzeitig erkennen soll,
ob jemand durchdreht.
Rund 140 Fälle von möglichen
Gefährdungen gab es im letzten Jahr,
vier Beamte klären ab.
Ein Computerprogramm
hilft bei der Einschätzung,
wie gefährlich diese Menschen
werden können.
Wahrscheinlich ist er psychotisch.
Er ist ziemlich auffällig.
War das in diesem Jahr?
In diesem Fall
würde ich es orange lassen.
Aber aus seinen Schreiben
geht hervor, dass ...
Es ist sehr wirr,
und es zeigt sich sehr ...
... diese Psychose
ist schon gegeben, denke ich.
Sarah Rudin ist Psychologin.
Sie versucht,
die Wutbürger zu verstehen.
Es gibt Drohungen, die häufig
im Behördenkontakt passieren.
Sie kommen aus einer Emotion heraus,
aus einer Wut heraus.
Sie müssen nicht jahrelang geplant
sein und so gemeint sein.
Die harmlosen von den
nicht harmlosen zu unterscheiden,
ist unsere tägliche Herausforderung.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Hätte die Polizei die Bluttat
von Alice F. verhindern können,
wenn sie genauer hingeschaut hätte?
Reden mit Querulanten nützt meistens,
so die Erfahrung in Liestal.
Endlich hört mir jemand zu.
Endlich interessiert sich jemand
für meine Sicht,
denn mir geht es
eigentlich auch nicht gut.
Ja, ich brauche Hilfe, ich nehme
die Unterstützung gerne an.
Das gibt es auch.
Meine Erfahrungen sind:
Gespräche mit Gefährdern
sind tendenziell eher positiv.
Bei Alice F. hätten sich aufgrund
der fehlenden Krankheitseinsicht
und Verweigerung der Beschuldigten
vor der Tat keine
Behandlungsmöglichkeiten geboten,
wird das Strafgericht des Kantons
Basel-Stadt später festhalten.
Nach der Tat
schrieb sie ihren Bekannten:
"Habe gerade ein Kind getötet."
Kurz darauf dreht sie zwei Runden
im nahe gelegenen Schützenmattpark.
Sie ruft den Lokalsender Telebasel an
und berichtet,
dass sie ohne Wohnung sei und soeben
einen Schulbuben umgebracht habe.
1 Std. nach der Tat stellt sich
Alice F. der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Sie erzählt, sie habe ein Kind
getötet - und händigt das Messer aus.
In den Akten heisst es: "Sie war
völlig ruhig und gefasst und sagte:"
'Ich habe etwas Dummes gemacht.'"
Vom Untersuchungsgefängnis aus
kämpft Alice F. weiter.
Sie ist schuldunfähig,
aber weil sie weiter gefährlich ist,
soll sie verwahrt werden.
Dagegen zieht sie
vor das Bundesgericht.
Sie verbietet ihrem Verteidiger
und ihren Freunden, mit uns zu reden.
Stattdessen schreibt sie
der Redaktion mehrere Briefe.
Darin steht:
"Der tatsächliche Sachverhalt
des Tatmotivs
sind die nachweisbaren,
schwerwiegenden Amtsverfehlungen."
Und weiter: "Das mir vorgeworfene
Tatmotiv Wahnvorstellungen
entspricht nicht der Tatsache."
Ein Jahr nach dem Delikt
findet die Gerichtsverhandlung statt.
Die Tat hat Alice F. nie bestritten.
Das Gericht muss jedoch feststellen,
ob sie dafür verantwortlich
gemacht werden kann.
Alice F. erscheint in geblümter Bluse
vor Gericht.
Sie sieht erholt aus.
In einem langen Monolog erzählt sie
von dem angeblichen Unrecht,
das ihr widerfahren sei.
Die Eltern des ermordeten Jungen
sitzen direkt hinter ihr.
Es war so schwer,
ihr in die Augen zu schauen.
Und sie lachte vor uns.
Am schlimmsten war es,
als wir im Gericht 45 Min. lang
ihrer Stimme zuhören mussten.
Wir mussten ihr
45 Min. lang zuhören,
in der sie
nur über ihre Sachen sprach.
Sie sprach
nur über ihre Privatsachen,
nicht über die Tat.
Und noch schlimmer war, dass sie
sich nicht bei uns entschuldigt hat.
Das Urteil lautet:
Alice F. hat den Mord begangen,
bestraft wird sie aber nicht -
wegen Schuldunfähigkeit.
Erklären Sie einmal einer
Opferfamilie, was schuldunfähig ist.
Man ist schuld, aber doch nicht.
Nach dem Mord an dem kleinen Ilias
legten die Trauernden
Blumen und Spielzeug nieder.
Bis heute
ist ein kleiner Teil davon geblieben.
Einige Anwohner wollen,
dass das von hier verschwindet.
Man müsse auch mal vergessen können -
für die Eltern ein schlimmer Gedanke.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Katja Faber kämpfte acht Jahre lang
für ein gerechtes Urteil -
auf eigene Rechnung.
Im Gegensatz zum Täter
stelle der Staat den Hinterbliebenen
nämlich
keinen unentgeltlichen Anwalt.
Ein Missstand, findet sie,
so wie die Tatsache, dass der Täter
nach zwei Dritteln der Strafe
bereits entlassen werden kann.
Jetzt, wo der Mann,
der Alex getötet hat,
bald auf Bewährung freikommt,
frage ich mich,
wie es für mich sein wird,
hier zu sein,
in Zürich, in Küsnacht.
Meine Beziehung zu diesem Ort,
von dem ich weiss,
ich könnte ihm begegnen -
das ist nicht einfach.
Aber ich will mir diesen Ort,
der so wunderbar und mit so vielen
schönen Erinnerungen verbunden ist,
nicht kaputt machen lassen.
Also habe ich mich dazu gezwungen,
immer wieder herzukommen.
Ich lasse mir diesen Ort
nicht nehmen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Roger Schmid - 2023